bueno más que la reunión en sí misma lo
que ha cobrado mucha importancia como tú
decías es esta región que se ha
convertido en un pívot fundamental en la
estrategia del indo pacífico de los eeuu
en un área de influencia natural de
china y justamente camboya es uno de los
países más cercanos a china en esta
región probablemente se sientan como
jugando de locales los chinos en este
escenario y también como tú decías no
hay grandes expectativas de que haya
reuniones bilaterales entre estos tres
cancilleres de los principales países
que van a estar participando más allá de
la agenda específica de la cea y uno de
los puntos que van a discutir en la base
adam es lo que ocurre en mianmar cuáles
son las las posturas respecto a la junta
militar y si en general respaldan como
lo hace rusia o se acercan más al
rechazo que ha mostrado occidente
bueno ahí tenemos un problema porque
justamente hay como tres grandes
posturas el rechazo de occidente que
está alineado que tiene en cuenta
digamos con apoyo de varios de los
países del asean por ejemplo singapur
una posición más bien cercana esta
dictadura que es la de rusia y china-
que se ha mantenido en una suerte de
neutralidad algo parecido a lo que ha
hecho la india que no es parte de este
bloque pero es un actor importante así
que esas tres grandes posturas que se
mantienen desde que esta junta tan
brutal ha tomado el poder y lo sigue
ejerciendo con total ligereza eso hace
complicado las negociaciones y es muy
poco probable también entonces que
tengamos algún avance en esta cumbre y
previamente hablábamos en este noticiero
de las tensiones entre china y taiwán
como estas relaciones impactan a los
países de la asean a
bueno las impactan muchísimo y los
preocupan pelosi de alguna forma con
este viaje ha dejado un campo minado en
términos diplomáticos hoy es más
probable que antes una invasión de china
a taiwán hoy es menos probable el
diálogo entre china y taiwán y entre
china y eeuu justamente en función de
este y otros temas
y en el medio quedan todos los países de
la asean mucho más débiles en términos
estratégicos que sufren directamente las
consecuencias de esta disputa es una
pena que la diplomacia de eeuu esté
orientando de esta forma porque lo que
hace es alejar la posibilidad de diálogo
y consensos en un montón de otros temas
que son relevantes para la región más
allá de taiwán y por ejemplo cuáles son
esos temas relevantes para la región muy
brevemente
bueno la conectividad básicamente ahí
hay una gran cuestión que es la nueva
ruta de la seda china
la estrategia del indo-pacífico el lindo
pacific framework que acaba fusión que
acaba de anunciar los eeuu así que la
cuestión es cómo mejorar la conectividad
cómo mejorar la seguridad energética
alimentaria el tema climático también es
muy importante esos son los temas
básicamente que le preocupan a los
países de la asean más allá de taiwán